my name is Scott Williamson I'm
president of the Yale Club of Chicago
and we're here for Yale Day of Service
and today we're at the Skokie lagoons
we're going to be removing invasive
species but farm garlic mustard that's
part of stewardship you are interacting
with people who might not otherwise
you're interacting with other alumni you
know you're doing something to mix a
little bit of difference to somebody and
I'm changing lives one of the biggest
lives it gets changed mine hi my name is
Ignacio core for I am the class of 95
from Yale University I also serve as
Secretary of the Yale Club of Chicago as
well as a vice president of the Yale
black alumni association national board
I'm very involved personally as a lawyer
here in Chicago in a number of volunteer
activities but one of the more enjoyable
is anything that has to do
yale yale always brings a very distinct
sense of community betterment that i
personally am alive
hi my name is robin wall joey and as a
graduate class of nineteen eighty-five
and over the last five years I've been
involved in a day of service I got
involved with refugees and partnering
with refugee organization about four
years ago and we began our work the idea
of the Yale day service is not to be
exclusive but to engage in many in
understanding and address addressing our
global issues today my name is Melissa
pugin I am on the board of the National
yo Latino Alumni Association my also
serve on the Yale Club of Chicago as
well on their board of directors today
we're actually here at Casa centered on
in the humble Park neighborhood of
Chicago casa san fran has been here for
60 years of celebrating its 60th
anniversary today and they serve the
predominant Latino community of Homo
park and variety of different services
including services for the elderly
as well as early education providing
after school options for perusal
students EOC of service is a
manifestation of that willingness and
desire to be part of whatever community
and where you are and whatever capacity
you can see the play and so this is why
I do yelled service and this is why I
continued you it and it also provides an
opportunity for people to come together
and so this come commonality that SEOs
we have does bring people together that
maybe at other more moments might have
haven't met each other and those bring
us to express this human commonality of
wanting to share service hi I'm Cheryl
division cetera and the director
volunteer engagement hairdresser
sometimes we just wanted to thank the
Yale alumni associations for giving back
on this day of service we are so
fortunate to partner with them it's so
important we're celebrating our 60th
year anniversary and to have groups like
the Yale on my associations come and
beautify our programs and space for the
families that come every day really
makes a difference and we couldn't do it
without partners like you
you